And someone would say, hey, Saqib.
Like actively confuse us.
And like somebody actually like had a...
We're live.
I think we're live.
Yeah, we're live.
But this is what it is about.
So unless it is HR or not inappropriate, we can keep talking.
Okay, start and show.
All right, cool.
Let's get people in.
So we started and I will give a couple more minutes for people to jump in.
Yeah.
Cool.
All right.
Super exciting.
I think lots of folks are starting to join.
Our favorite question.
The most repeated question every webinar has been, are we recording this?
So yes, we are recording.
And I think also the most commonly used.
So I mentioned about it in Corona America.
So one of our event manager question is, where is everyone joining from?
So why don't we start with that?
Sorry.
Oh, I got my ribbon.
Thank you.
So will do.
So thanks everyone for joining.
And if anybody can do that, that's my White Hat 42じゃ between you and me.
Thank you.
And the link to this Q&A is about like...
Well.
Wow, you're folks joining from East Coast, West Coast, UK, Asia.
Amazing.
England.
This time apparently works for everyone, I guess, Vakas.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm surprised to see folks from Asia also joining us.
It's incredible.
Yeah, yeah.
Germany.
Every time zone, almost.
I haven't seen anyone from Australia or New Zealand yet.
We'll see.
No one from Spain.
Yeah.
They are hungover.
They are hungover, yes.
We had a couple of folks from Spain joining in, actually.
I know at least one person who runs as an operating partner in one of the VC firms had joined.
Oh, amazing.
Okay.
Cool.
Well, we can kick it off.
And I think as folks trickle in, we can at least start with some of the quick intros and then context setting.
So first and foremost, welcome, everyone.
Really glad you're here.
This is our session three.
And it's impressive that every time we have a wait list gets longer and longer on this one.
So thanks again for joining us and giving us feedback, by the way.
Keep giving us candid feedback.
We're going to be doing a lot of feedback on things to fix, improve, and so forth.
The quick context before we jump in, and Rajan, please jump in as well.
But the reason we started this series is because a lot of the marketing that includes partner management, community building, DevRel, et cetera, in the broader realm, a lot of the AI, going AI conversations are still very vibes based.
And what we wanted to have less of a conversation.
So we're going to be talking about the AI.
We're going to be talking about the AI.
Less polished, more real life issues, challenges, landmines, and what's actually working in real life and things to look for as you go and take your first step towards AI-fying your workflows.
So that's the series is all about.
We keep it super informal and very, as Rajan said, very anti-webinar style.
And it's meant to be that way.
Yeah.
So the last thing I'll say is that this time I'm really excited because of two of my friends who work with and we still stay in touch.
So that speaks a lot from previous lives.
And so we have Saqib who runs partner marketing at Anthropic.
Previously he's built a 10,000 partner plus ecosystem at Snowflake from like really like nothing.
Yeah.
And it's like, it's incredible how they've been able to go from a very incubation to a really scaled motions.
Would love to learn from his and all the, all the mistakes is made, especially along the way.
And then Guan who has built data analytics systems at some of the most advanced companies, Airtable recently, Snowflake, Navon and so forth.
And he will talk about how the stack has shifted.
And how he would think, do things differently as in the, in the age of AI.
That's amazing.
And before we jump in just to add on, right.
One of the things that Vakas and I noticed is we used to go to these panels quite a bit.
Everyone was talking about, oh, AI agents is taking over jobs or taking is going to take everyone's job.
And also everything we heard was more forward looking.
This is going to happen.
That is going to happen.
So.
So one of the things that Vakas and I wanted to change was we have already leaders who are doing these things.
We're already, already started implementing it.
Why don't we bring them together and learn from them?
And I think the best way of learning of how, how we want to work and the cutting edge is learning from others, not just from trying to hear what would happen.
So that's why we started the cities and that's why we call this series as like AI native marketing cities now.
And the goal is like, everyone should be able to do that.
And everyone.
How did we start and what things broke along the way before we built a system, which is automating a big chunk of our thing.
So that's it.
And before we go dive in, before we hand it over to Sakeb and go on just a quick intro for folks who don't know me, I'm Rajan.
I used to run marketing at Cohere, one of the foundational model company and after that at Together AI.
And now I help AI native companies, mostly on infra, dev tools and agents on marketing and growth.
And.
The funny story is that.
I was a developer in my past life.
Marketers thought that I'm too technical and developers thought that I'm non-technical.
So I'm still finding my way around where to fit.
But this place gives me a really good idea where we have marketers as well as your technical leaders coming in from DevRel and the communities.
Vakas, you want to do a quick intro?
Hi, I'm Vakas.
I lead DevRel and community at Nebius, previously at OpenAI and Snowflake and very excited to kick it off.
So I'm going to give you a quick intro.
I'm going to give you a quick intro.
Cool.
All right.
Well, who do you want to hand it off to first?
Sakeb?
Let's start with Sakeb.
He's ready to go.
And Sakeb, hand over the stage to you and all yours.
Take it away.
Yeah, absolutely.
So I think we want to keep it a lively discussion.
So fundamentally, I've had the chance of building and helping build multiple partner ecosystems.
Right.
And before this, I was actually like a technical person.
I think being a marketer.
So Rajen, to your point, like, hey, you need to be a little bit technical and know your
product and need to know how to write SQL to use a data warehouse because they behave
in very specific ways compared to an OLAP database.
I know that much of a difference.
I can be dangerous enough.
I think that's super important, understanding how the technology works.
I would always say to young marketers, like, hey, get your technology.
You know, tech jobs, right?
Like, know your technology, the one you're selling.
It also helps you make a decision.
A lot of people come to me and ask me, like, hey, how do you go from like, you know, Snowflake
to Anthropic to other organizations where you're making the right product decisions
and stuff?
And I always say, like, I will look out for the right people, the culture and the right
product and go from there.
So I think understanding the product is super important and going from there.
I think the things that I want to kind of highlight today are.
Yeah.
I think the things that I want to highlight today are, hey, how do we use AI in, you know,
at Anthropic?
And I'm going to go through some of the examples I was able to, like, just kind of produce
myself today and think about it.
I think the fundamental thing that changed for me was and I give credit where credit's
due.
I'm very lucky to have hired really smart people on my team.
I have a very, very high bar for my team and I've hired some really smart ones.
And one of them built a really cool entire workflow in cloud.
And I'm not going to show you that entire workflow, propriety and stuff and everything,
but like I'm going to go through a couple of examples of how things we look about and
see and go from there, because that will help you understand, like, hey, where to take this
stuff.
Right.
A lot of a lot of people ask me, like, hey, you know, when you're building ecosystems
and stuff.
How do you build for scale?
Like right now, you're seeing thousands of these partners attached to yourself.
And so, you know, the number one question that comes up is, hey, can you build content
with us?
You know, I'm quoting an example, right?
It's easy.
You can you can pull content together in in things really easily and go from there.
You know, one thing that, you know, I took up I used to be called what a funny thing
about myself is when I was going to uni.
I used to be called a caller.
So I took that name and turned it into calls.
So you'll notice I named my organization the KLC partner content partner organization.
Right.
So you can see I'm sharing something right now.
I'm going from there.
These are just partner content guidelines that I asked Claude to go right and dealt
in two minutes.
Right.
You can kind of go through what is how to talk about our product, what's approved, what's
not approved, those sort of things.
A little bit more qualitative.
Right.
So you can see here, you know, we have partner tiering, statistics, claims, codes, road map,
you know, those sort of things.
Brand logo usage.
Every company has this.
Right.
Every company has this takes about two minutes to develop and Claude.
Great.
Awesome.
But now how do you use this in a workflow is super important.
Right.
So now you come to like, hey, how do I make sure I am developing this?
And.
In a way that I can actually share this with people and partners to scale out their content.
So I just over the weekend, I just sat down and I kind of said like, okay, Claude, help
me build a, you know, a little bit of a portal where I can actually share some of this with
partners.
So, you know, you can build a form like this, which is really easy and tell the partners
to submit the content here.
And.
I did.
And, you know, took an ABC corporation, right?
You have thousands of partners who are submitting these on a regular basis.
You know, you have, if you have a thousand partners and 10% of them submitted, that's
a hundred documents that are submitted.
Right.
They want to make announcements.
They want to do blogs.
They want to do technical stuff.
They want to do all of these things.
Right.
And we have a scoring rubric.
Five, one to five, five means okay to publish.
One means you need a lot of work here.
Right.
Okay.
So we put this together and we submitted it for review.
And the contents here.
Okay.
So we have a lot of work here.
Copy pasted.
Look, it actually gives you like a lot of the details in non-tier, you know, feedback.
It gives you a rubric of one, like, Hey, look, you need a lot of changes here.
You need to make sure you're doing this correctly.
Gives you suggested language and all of those things.
Right.
And these are just like, Hey, this is a workflow that is done by every partner marketing person
on a regular basis.
And you're talking about.
Sometimes.
Five to 10 documents a day.
Right.
And how do you make sure you're just kind of going through and identifying all of these
things.
And then plus on top of it, like, Hey, can you just draft it, put it in word, put it
in Google docs, do you want a partner email, send it to the partner boom, done.
Right.
And go from there.
So it's an entire workflow that you're building into that thing.
I think that this is the thing that you need to kind of keep in mind is how do you build
the entire.
Workflows into all of this.
Okay.
Then the third part of all of this is internal.
Like, can I see things internally on what is being approved?
What is not being approved?
Right.
Can I do reminders and findings and capture all of these things?
So to make sure that like, Hey, this partner has been provided feedback.
These partners are doing really well.
Like Northwind is for example, getting all their content.
Right.
Awesome.
Great to work with ABC Corp.
Not so much.
Right.
And this is like one of those things, which like when you talk about customer references,
PR blogs, all of those things, these things start piling up.
How do you make your people much more efficient so they can actually think about innovative
ideas of doing things with our partner.
So this is just a short workflow that I built by the way, honestly, really, really frankly,
once you put the workflow down on paper or like you just think about it a little bit
and take a step back.
Okay.
So what I did was I took a couple of minutes and I had to do some revisions, but like in
15 minutes I was done with this entire portal, the sample docs, the, all of the sample data
and everything.
Wow.
Right.
And I did it yesterday before the world cup game, I was pre-recording it.
I had a 30 minute delay.
I was like, this is a good time to kind of get this task done.
So that's the sort of stuff that you should be thinking about.
Like, Hey, how do you take a workflow?
Not just one task, but a workflow and completely define it.
I think that's like level two of things.
I think somewhere down the line, we'll start thinking about how to make this a product,
shipping this out and proliferating this and giving more users access.
So like these sort of tools are now exposed to our partner portal and going from there.
So I think it makes life much, much easier.
Yeah.
In fact, in our partner portal, we actually use an integration to, you know, expose cloud
into our partner portal and go from there.
So you can, partners can easily ask questions.
It's actually called a partner manager AI.
And so they can easily ask questions and don't have to do that.
So I'll take a pause there.
Questions for me.
Sorry, go ahead, Vukas.
I was just going to say this is super impressive.
And I know that there are partner teams I work with where they have hired several full-time
people just to manage this because they want to crank out content, but there's humans there.
And it still has long delays and getting back to partners, fixing things and a lot of like
stuff that is sitting there.
So I think it's a good time to start thinking about that.
Yeah.
I think it's a good time to start thinking about that.
So I think it's a good time to start thinking about that.
But I think it's a good time to start thinking about that.
I think it's a good time to start thinking about that.
Yeah, I think it's a good time to start thinking about that.
And I know that there are partner teams I work with where they have hired several full-time
people just to manage this because they want to crank out content, but there's humans there.
And it still has long delays in getting back to partners, fixing things, and a lot of stuff
that is sitting there.
So I was just going to ask the question that was here, which is somebody is asking what
tools are you using to build this on.
I built all of this in Cloud, all of this in Cloud, but I'm going from there.
We do have a PRM.
A partner.
manager skin that we have kind of used on top of it on top of our partner portal but like
all of this was google docs and uh applaud frankly so i think i think this is great right because i
think a lot of the folks uh sometimes they feel like oh look i can just prompt something and get
something done right how do you how do you make it production worthy as you scale and make sure
that this becomes like a rubric that your team follows overall um that's a really good question
i think that's where like you have to have some sort of a change management you know i'd love to
hear from go on like how do you do operationalize some of this right but i think the thing is that
as long as the way i see it is as long as you keep on maintaining your partner marketing guidelines
really well and the team kind of does that you can feed those into the tool itself to give feedback
on a regular basis
right and so your north star is that partner marketing guidelines what you're not doing is
sitting down on a manual basis and comparing the bottom marketing guidelines to something written
by others and go from there got it and how how do you how do you ensure right like some of these
would need thinking about like this is how my actual workflow works and fine-tuning it right
once you see like few rounds of it happening how do you identify these are the areas that i need to
improve
within my workflow these are the areas that i now need to extend right so you have the
initial submission the identifying of like the ratings overall how do you then extend think about
extending your workflow as you start automating more and more man this is why i love these tools
um hands down like you know this is basic right we built it and i can already see people like asking
questions about it and stuff in the chat i think the fundamental thing is that you kind of take
input from your stakeholders they have a lot of work to do i think in terms of like you're you're
already in a certain area where you're like you're working on something or you're working on something
you're working on something right and you're working on a particular tool or you're working on something
folders and you see the input and you kind of decide like, hey, here's the feature functionality
I'm going to keep on building, right? And go from there. So I think that is where it becomes
a very interactive sort of, you know, a creative sort of a process of the tool development, right?
Get the base level right, get the base level consistent, start using them. But as soon as you
get users using them, they come up with their own ideas of like, here are the five questions I want
to ask and go from there and do it accordingly. And then after that, it's like, yeah, you know
what? Sounds good. I'll love to kind of do the, add more features and stuff and both sort of things.
I see on a continuous basis, like what's happened in my team is a couple of people owning certain
data tents, I would say. I don't even want to say dashboards or anything now anymore,
but they kind of take iterative improvements from people and they're
stakeholders and keep on improving their data tents and their insights tents. And that
becomes a really good way of like including stuff. Like last night, yesterday, somebody on my team
was like updating their dashboard on a regular basis, just that kind of taking input. And it
was just phenomenal to see like the sort of, you know, growth you can show through those sort of
things and narrow down where your problems are and go from there. Got it. And this is great. And
one of the questions that are coming in is like, how do you ensure, right? You have a team,
how do you ensure that you have a team that is able to do the work that you're doing?
How do you ensure that the team is collaborating into extending this workflows or the knowledge
base so that they can use it collectively versus like this becoming like a one person tool that
only one, only they can, they can use it for their, for their own workflow?
Yeah, I think we almost can go through a process of like initially when we deploy something,
like all of us say, Hey, does it work for us or not? Right. What are the changes that can be made
from there? And then after it is
adopted by a few people, then roll it out to like, Hey, here are the changes we are going to actively
make on a regular basis. Right. Also making sure that you declare on any of these tools, like, Hey,
this tool is meant to build X, not to do Y. Right. And go from there. Like the sort of tools that I
just showed you is not a content generator. It's a content reviewer, right? If you suddenly say,
generate all my content for that. No, that's not fair. Um, for that tool. Um, it's not meant for,
for that, you know, you can use other tools for that. There's a ton of tools for that. It's a
reviewer. It's not a reviewer and a tracker sort of thing. So
I think this, this is, this is amazing. Abhikash, go ahead.
There's one more question and we'll keep going because there's a lot of interest in this. And
that question was more around, uh, were you using any agencies? It sounds like this is one of those
things that can pretty much cut out. This was historically a very agency, um, uh, type of things
you can kind of outsource to them, but this.
This is like, you're probably not using any contractors agencies now, right? You really
cut out that cost.
I, we use agencies for different purposes. We have a ton of agencies that we use. Um, you know,
they can be sometimes our boots on the ground. They can be sometimes helping us with things
that we need to scale out in a physical manner and go from there. I think it, uh, it, um, it
helps us make sure that we are focusing on the most important.
Task to solve.
Yeah.
And then give agencies the tasks that are more repeatable in nature or where we don't feel like,
Hey, we should spend human capital on these things and go from there. Um, but yeah, you know,
now we're able to like kind of direct a lot of the agencies in a very different way. But that doesn't
mean that agencies or other things go away. It just means that it's focused on the right things
we should be doing.
Amazing. So do you have more to show to us?
No, I will take questions now. So I don't want, I don't want,
um, uh, just hog the demo. So.
I have two. I'll ask with one first start with the first one, which is, do you sort of continue
to fine tune this, the skill, the skills of this as you, as you build it and how does that work?
Yeah. Not only do we fine tune this, this actually like becomes now skills that we can share with
different teams on our behalf. Right. So like when we go up the ladder and you know, you have to
report up to some of the, um,
um,
execs, they will always ask how many customer references, for example, well, we can kind of show
on a board now, Hey, taking from all of this, here are the customer references that were done. Here are
the ones that are approved. Let's go through that cycle and go from there. Um, and sometimes they,
uh, the ask is like, what are the most interesting ones, you know, because like how many keynotes
have we done? Right. And it's always like, what are the human aspect stories? What are these
stories? What are the other things that we're searching on? And it's always like, well, I gotta
go back and like, look through the long list of customer references.
Yeah.
Um, a lot of this is made easier now. Um, because now you can kind of say, oh, this content came
out. It's super interesting from a beneficial deployments perspective. Let's kind of tap it and
go, uh, push it to those guys.
Amazing. That's great. Uh, one, one question around like how you are thinking about,
this is one part of the workflow on the partner marketing side, right? I think the audience
were also allowed to understand a little bit more around how it was now structured, like how you
build your partner marketing team.
Right. To work around some of these workflows and what are some of the extended workflows that they
use in addition to this reviewer agent workflow? Yeah. I think the thing to kind of, um, think
about there is that every partner marketer now needs to think about themselves as a business
owner, including myself. So like, you know, um, while, uh, you know, um, I help, uh, with the
team, I also manage part of the business. So that's there. I think the other part of it is
that every partner marketer now has to report back.
On the business in a certain way. It's not just about like, Hey, I ran these many events with
partners boom, done these many leads. It's like, what is the health of the overall business and
how am I contributing in the right manner? Right. And go from there. Um, so I think that's where it
becomes super important to like hire business owners and people who can independently run it.
And then think about it from their perspective. Like they will probably say, Hey, I've got these
two or three things that are super important to my stakeholders.
That is what I'll report back on the other stuff kind of becomes a supporting function from all
of this. And then make sure that like, Hey, you know, we are not going to scale these teams to
support all of the partners, you know, suddenly like, you know, uh, if you have a 10,000 partner
organization, you're not going to hire like, you know, 500 partner marketing folks. That's not
going to happen, you know? And so you have to make sure that you're supporting all of these other
partners to like, because I think mentioned.
To keep a consistent message, to keep a consistent story, to keep a consistent thing from all of
these things. I wish, you know, man, five years ago, this was available to us when, because I
think we were going through some messaging changes at Snowflake and we were going from the data
warehouse built for the cloud to the data cloud and the tracking on all of that was so difficult
and making those changes was so, um, uh, tough and going from there. And I wish a lot of this
was available at that time. It would make life.
A lot more easier.
Yeah.
On the right things. So yeah, the scale was so huge and then yeah, everything was sort of like
in the absence of that, as much as automation you can put in, it was still very, very rigid
and you couldn't do it. I remember. Yeah. Yeah. I think now you can just apply this to that and
put the rubric there.
We have a lot of questions coming in. Uh, one, one question that Indy brought up was what's the
right model. Uh, uh, Sakep.
Yeah.
Is it more around one app per workflow or you think that there is like a master app for partner
marketing that runs multiple workflows as streamlined version of it that may be more mature,
how mature teams work?
Yeah, that's a great question. I think there's, uh, I think it starts solving from one app or
workflow, but slowly it becomes into like a hub for all the apps.
Hmm.
Right. And goes from there. So I think that's where, um, you know,
don't let this don't let perfection be the enemy of good and get it out there.
Um, that shouldn't happen in the product side, frankly, but on this side, like, Hey,
this is my philosophy, you know, different people have different philosophies, but I think like
getting it out there is important, but slowly then start thinking about like with the proliferation
of these tools, you know, I bet Guan has a better philosophy on all of this. I want to hear from him
about this.
Um, but with the.
Yeah.
The proliferation of some of these things, it's all about like, okay, now let's bring it into,
uh, you know, overarching platform or product sort of a thing and go from there. I think this is
something that like kind of happens, you know, you drove all these features and suddenly you realize
you become a platform for internal users or external users.
Yeah. I remember, I think one of the previous sessions, uh, uh, Nino from the growth marketing
came in and topic had joined and very similar. He had a very similar approach that I started with,
like one small,
um,
part of my entire,
uh,
performance marketing workflow.
And then he went on and building that entire system and workflows where it had different layers around reviewers,
the different layers around integration with the tools,
et cetera.
So I think it's very similar approach that I've seen,
uh,
work.
Uh,
as you said,
don't let perfection and the,
and the most sophisticated thing get into your way to start,
start finding,
finding ways to,
uh,
start using it.
Yeah.
The one thing I've learned in the AI space is do it now.
I think,
uh,
I,
I remember this one QBR in snowflake where,
um,
Mike's cart.
Ali said,
why aren't we doing it right now?
And,
uh,
that was like a,
I hope not all of us.
I think that spirit has just gone on overdrive at AI,
uh,
with AI,
like do it now,
let's figure out how to do it now.
Um,
and the tools exist.
It was,
it was,
um,
that like more simplified version.
Yeah.
It was hyped up for gemeins,
but I found like tri COMs and it was really great.
That as this asker,
it didn't do either for gemeins.
It did do that for always,
but ultimately it looked in our creates sequence and we followed it to
Solutions Digital.
So we looked at,
and then we pushed,
uh,
watched them up through jalopies,
finalized the particular gone not as an AI scenario,
but it was,
it was going toλη I guess like golden,
like to give you people some aplomb in,
to keep it real.
But I know that's
like world peace.
Even as a
vegetarian,
I would prefer no potatoes
in my biryani.
How is that possible?
I would use
paneer instead of potatoes,
if you ask me.
I'm going to have a great biryani then.
Now I'm hungry.
We have so many questions coming up.
But I think...
Go ahead, Saqib.
I think I covered a lot
of scope, but if you guys have any
questions to ask me...
I do have one.
I'm generally curious.
Partner marketing is one of the few functions
that are very relationship, heavily
relationship-focused.
Every single thing turns out to be
let's meet first.
A lot of stakeholders get...
It's very relationship-oriented.
Everybody is in the same field.
So how do you automate this
without losing that human touch piece of it?
Oh, that's a very good question.
And I think the fact of the matter is
that that relationship piece doesn't go away.
You still have to be very good at it.
I think what does become really good
is the fact that...
And I'm going to quote an example.
Somebody on my team has a computer and they're like,
you know, I'm a computer guy.
on my team has built a very good tool of partner standings. And it automatically gives you a slide
ready for QBR on an active basis on what is the partner standing in terms of working with them
and marketing activities and all of those things. That is a very data-driven slide, which takes out
the human emotion out of a relationship and says like, hey, here's where you're great, here's where
you're not. And those are the sort of discussions you should have in person, but to arm themselves
with that sort of a data and that sort of a standing and that sort of a thing. And even like
what that person's done is like made sure that that slide is available to all the partner managers
so that they can transparently see where their partner stands, right? It's a very good thing
because that makes life really easy for them to have that discussion. So like, I'll just say this,
like,
they can kind of just get it, the relationship part becomes much more important because now you
have much more time to do that relationship part rather than saying, hey, I am now focusing on,
you know, this just the relationship part. I think that that whole process of building that
relationship is much more data-driven than go from there. Yeah. Yeah. I'm just, yeah. Okay.
Reasons are no. Brianni and Ray,
reasons do not go together. Like that is just a no, like let's not do that.
I like how this session is going from.
I was going to say that this could become a model name too.
Okay, cool. This.
One more question that's summing up. I think this is very important, right? So Sakib,
I think internally, a lot of the things that I'm assuming at Anthropic, your team and other teams
are using, right? How do you generally think about like, hey, this is the ROI for how,
you know, partner marketing now can produce and this is where the investment should go in going
forward. How do you define that? I think ROI is this like fundamental question of like,
hey, how do you, how do you serve the end goals that you're being measured on? Right?
So the end goals that are being measured on, that is what you need to keep in mind.
Right. Can you serve those in an efficient way? In the beginning of the year, we were given this
target and I was just like, oh my God, what am I going to do? And I sat down with my team member
and we're both like thinking like scratching our head, like, hey, how are we going to do this?
And we really discovered a different way of doing things on that target. And I think like any time
that that person spent on developing the automation and the workflow for this was super, super good
from the perspective.
Of like, we thought we would have to hire two people to manage the entire process and to develop
the folks, the portables and stuff. And we did it all in this thing. And now we've actually crossed
the target. We have to think about like upping our target. So I think that is how we need to
think about ROI is like, hey, take an ROI on an objective that is really concrete and then go hard
after it with the automation.
And do it. And we did it within a quarter and go from there. So yeah, I just say that's the way I
would look at ROI. ROI doesn't always mean just dollars though. It means-
It's so important. Yes. Because every time you see people it's like, hey, look,
how much dollar is going to save me? And I think that's the wrong way to look at ROI,
especially if using, and I completely agree with you there.
It could be saving hours. It could be developing more content that is genuinely,
good content. It could be dealing more customer references. It could be doing a ton more with
what you have existing and making your people. Hell, you know what? It could be that all of
us go home at 5 30 PM and that is a great ROI for the people who work. And all of us get vacation
and stuff and those sorts of things. Fieldworks.
Yeah. Yeah.
Sakib, one question for anyone who is like a small or solo partner
in a team with large number of partners they have to manage and lots of chaos. What are one or two
workflows they should absolutely go and automate starting tomorrow?
I think the number one thing about partnerships more and more getting measured is customer
references. So figure out how to do customer references. Number two is
demand is a little bit-
Yeah.
A little bit of a thing, but it depends, varies from partnership to partnership. So demand
generation maybe, but I think number one is customer references. Number two, I would say is
content and consistency of content and brand enforcement. Those are really important. I think
any brand, any, because the partners is the one place where your messaging can get lost. And so
making sure that you have consistency is very, very important. And going from there.
And showing up from that perspective.
So I think the question is what do you mean by customer references? How do you-
Publicly mentionable customer references. How do partners can submit them, approve them,
get them ready, publish them, get all the way to sharing them with your sales and their sales and
all of those things, and sharing them in the right channels. And yeah, joint customer references.
Yeah.
I think one of the- well, there's a funny thread going on in the comments, like, Oh, I can't do this, but I'm going to update that in my office.
I think that's definitely one of the-
Yeah.
There's a funny thread going on in the comments, like, you know, or something similar,
in the comments like hey automating your boss's job should be the roi
it shouldn't be measured you know what every once in a while i say um this is private but
i say to my team like hey figure out how to automate my job and that is uh uh that's a
tough thing to say but it's i think somewhere down the line like automation of my job will
mean that i get to do more of the fun stuff yeah i get to think about net new projects that are
super cool and think big and let go from there um i think that those are the things that are super
important um you know how many times have we all been stuck in like oh i need to produce this one
slide for one pbr and those sort of things and it's like if we can get some of this stuff automated
um life is easier on all of us and gives us time to think about the smarter things in life to do
that's so true right and one of the things that i have a funda is like it is always about now what
can you do more right versus like how can you save cost how can you save the head counts overall
because i think the aggression of companies have increased now because they can do a lot more so
you don't want to be the only one who wants to do the same thing with less time and less resources
now i think that's what i've seen and when i talk to founders it's like yes now i want to accelerate
my roadmap it's not like now i want to do the same thing with less people i want to do the same thing
with more people and that's always been the consistent approach that i hear yeah yeah by the
way our partner marketing team and leaders messaging me on slack that like they're they're
really happy they've learned a lot from what you're saying sakeb as well as we're in the middle
of at nibius putting together these and implementing these workflows so it's a great
example of kind of applying that to and learning from each other that's amazing now that's good and
i just got a text from one of my dear friend david who i worked and he's like
love this uh i'm gonna order biryani for lunch and i was like yes this is this there's some roi
already my purpose if we can get something and uh this is amazing and david like really great
thanks for joining us this session and texting me uh but this is amazing uh cool uh so uh sakit
you're gonna hang around for a while and if you wanna answer the questions in the comments feel
free to continue to do that uh and uh now we're gonna hand it over to guan uh
guan you wanna take it away sure yeah so sake you you have done such great job always remember
uh you know i i was when sakiba was talking i remember our old days working together a snowflake
and sakiba is always ahead of me for the qbr so it's always hard to follow okay so i'm gonna share
my screen uh my talk is a little bit content heavy um although i'm a technical data and ai guy so
there's noeline on the one more抵яг. station if and at the top of the way so you'll notice
as now going on you want collater that is um more competencies experiences as well
um i wanted to bring up something here i'm going one um it's an honour to be start you know just
standing in front of you know all the amazing growth and marketing leaders here to cover
this topic my topic today is building ai and native data platform for growth you know today i
would share a little bit more technical stuff um if you're looking at my background um you know over
16 years um i've been building like data and ai teams and you know products across um opportunities
multiple hyper growth companies, including Snowflake,
where I had overlap with both SideKeep and Orcus.
I had a front row seat to really observe
every major enterprise software transition
from analytics, traditional analytics, to data science,
and later on to data platform.
And very recent, couple years, got into predictive analytics,
especially leveraging machine learning and ML ops.
And today, especially last year or so, everyone on this planet
were trying to build real AI agents and AI operating
systems.
Over the last 16 years, I noticed one really undeniable
truth is every previous technology
we've changed how software was built,
and this AI we've really changed how organizations
make decisions.
In the old world, software was passive system,
just keeping data in CRM or keeping data, sending an email.
But now with the AI native world, a lot of things
can be automated, especially the specific examples
or use cases SideKeep just covered.
That's a great testimonial for us.
Let's just take a look from like, what
are the most common things that we do?
So the first thing is to do the reality check.
In the growth and marketing world, there's so much data.
Look at this journey map.
Every single person in this room has built a stack similar to this.
We have tens or sometimes hundreds of systems applications.
They all capture some kind of data,
such as engagement in marketo or social intent, social content,
or engagement on linking.
And then we have all these kinds of things
that we can do on like a real works,
or AdRoll, and pay search on Google Ads, Facebook.
And also field activities.
We often logged in Salesforce or maybe Outreach, et cetera.
We're just capturing all this incredible amount of customer
engagement and intent.
But here's like I would say million dollar question, how can
we use all these kind of signals?
we don't need to struggle like how can we convert those you know those signals or data into timely
actions for for our for field there's some massive opportunities and very very costly for all of us
you know if we didn't do something um properly if we didn't build something properly you know if the
decisions are action then coordinate properly we basically lost opportunities you know you know
with all the noises happening around us and you know this is really the signal to decision gap
and we've we've been seeing um you know even in the in in the age of um ai
why do traditional gtm frameworks on four shot um i i would say voice down into three architecture
bottlenecks um first of all because of static um static rules um you know a lot of companies still
using you know you know you know you know you know you know you know you know you know you know
you know you know you know you know you know you know you know you know you know you know you know
you know traditional you know scoring methodology to look all across all signals you know that's
give this white people download 10 points and we can you know rank against all the leads and
contacts and accounts etc you know this is like really a measure of a single isolated action
the second is even when we use a machine learning approach
this was approach my teams in the past 10-ish years have been using they tend to look at
isolated
events but lack really an end-to-end understanding of the customer journey.
They don't connect the dots.
And finally, with drawing in data, especially as we saw the massive customer journey map,
just so much signal, so much noise.
And historically, we don't have a way to connect all these dots together.
Now with AI, this is really the exciting part.
Today, we're really excited to share this AI-native GTM operating model.
It is built on three core pillars.
Work in perfect harmony or harness, in the AI world, everyone calls it that way,
compounding over time.
The compounding growth framework really encompass three things.
One is predictive machine learning model.
The second thing is AI reasoning.
And the third thing is AI analytics.
And the third thing is closed-loop learning.
Regarding machine learning, predictive machine learning model, this is not new.
You build your machine learning infrastructure foundation, and then you can basically predict
how likely an account or individual people, individual lead or contact they're going to convert,
whether individual customer will renew, et cetera.
So that's a very traditional thing.
Thinking of this layer of step
as a noise filtering, especially for a company like an anthropic snowflake,
that's like hundreds of thousands or millions of leads coming on a weekly or monthly basis,
just too much.
You never will be able to hire enough people in the field to work on those leads.
So this machine learning, predictive machine learning model becomes an engine that can help you remove
and redo the noises there.
The second pillar of this operating framework is AI.
The third pillar of this operating model is agentic AI capability.
This is something I personally got very, very excited about in the last year or so,
even last few months.
Once machine learning flags help us prioritize all the leads and accounts of persons,
the agentic AI really steps in.
It can really reason across your entire customer journey,
all your accounts, all your people in your database, in your CRM,
look across all the signals and then basically help you figure out for this particular account,
this particular individual,
what are the key signals relevant to this individual account?
And before your field, SDR, AE talks to any account or any person,
basically the AI provides the signal.
It provides the reasoning behind it.
Thinking of this step as talking to the right people at the right account at the right time
based on the relevant context.
And this could never have been done before the AI era.
Machine learning is very capable of doing ranking, recommendation,
but they cannot reason based on the context we had before.
And then the last pillar of this operating model is really the closed loop feedback.
This is where the compounding in fact really is happening today.
Every time an AI agent recommends a play or specific action,
a user takes a specific action,
the system actually measures the actual business outcomes.
And then that could really become the feedback loop.
Your AI,
system,
and also your machine learning can be improved based on this automatic loop.
And your go-to-market engine literally gets smarter with every single decision it makes
and it compounds over time.
And thinking of this pillar as the step,
when a fully automated customer feedback to really help you improve your GTM engine.
And this,
you know,
let's take a look how this operating,
this,
you know,
this operates step by step.
First,
you must ingest all your real time signals,
your data from Salesforce,
your product usage.
I think that's a huge,
huge piece.
I have four more team members who are working at Anthropic.
They're building all these data pipelines to put,
you know,
from the cloud code skills and code to the data.
And then they're putting all their skills and co-work,
all their data into their internal data platforms.
You know,
campaign engagement from marketing side,
all the channels,
you know,
partners,
your Google ads,
your linking ads,
your Instagram ads,
you know,
TikTok,
et cetera,
all this data,
put all the data in your data platform.
And,
you know,
and a lot of times they also have a lot of sole parties contacts,
signals that's from Bombora or Intent data,
not necessarily tied to specific individual data.
So,
you know,
you can be a digital person,
but you know,
at account level what's happening,
you know,
your PR campaigns,
public relations,
your earnings report,
all those things can be,
you know,
now with,
very easy data,
AI powered data pipelining tools.
You can build all the data pipelines and pump into your internal data,
data platform.
Then you can use predictive models,
really,
you know,
basically pair your predictive machine learning models with,
your AI reasoning,
Power BI AI to really evaluate not just who might buy,
but also when and why they're going to take actions.
Next,
you,
once you translate all those raw data signals into business contact,
you know,
identify the buying committee and group are really important.
And then you,
we,
you know,
the AI operating system can provide the exact live stage where they are right now and what they are doing.
And finally,
I think you can build an autonomous,
autonomous agents that can execute targeted campaigns or even post personalized outreach in,
in,
you know,
there's a tool called outreach before you send a campaign,
you can really package all these contacts and,
you know,
and before,
human can also stay in the room,
you know,
before they execute anything,
you can really,
you know,
you can leave the email,
the communication channel,
or send on the phone,
anything human reviews on the message or email before the,
the campaign went out.
And last but not least notice this whole thing is a loop.
It's,
you know,
really builds on trusted data foundation,
shared memory.
That's really important.
Every action you take,
every recommendation,
your AI agents make every predictive model,
your machine learning produces,
keep all this in your data platform and then feedback learning.
This is a whole part of it.
So you can really build on this,
your AI agents take home every action,
every recommendation your AI agents make,
every predictive model,
your machine learning produces.
Keep all this in your data platform.
And then feedback learning.
This is a whole important thing.
So I'm sure that,
all this in your data platform and then feedback learning this is a whole loop just goes forever
you know on and you can and this once the roof um is on basically you can build the you know the
this whole kind of self-improvement loop and engine that your ai you know operating system
just becomes smarter and smarter every single every single day is it great go on this is super
this is great framing for like what is a um ideal setup looks like where like you know like let's say
that the teams are able to build this i guess the first question that i have is that where do you
think most um growth slash films analytics teams are today uh in this journey and then the second
is like as an outcome of what you've built recently with gen ai what have you been able to
sort of like extract from the data that you've built and then what are the things that you've
been able to do to make it work for you and then what are the things that you've been able to do to
or get some insight for the business that was not possible before let's say about a year ago or even
18 months ago or so yeah yeah so for your question you know my observations with a lot of
organizations um you know they're still trying to move into like a lot more of data into the
internal data platforms so first first okay got it yeah i think a lot of companies still
struggling but you know for like industry leading companies you know like anthro
pick and you know like snowflake and databricks those companies they're definitely much much
advanced you know ahead of a lot of their peers why do you think they're struggling sorry
um i think a lot of companies still struggling like building their like a data pipelines to
that's it if they use snowflake right they're still trying to figure out how can they you know
pump all the data into snowflakes that's you know i think you know i think maybe my observations they
are like me maybe like lee leadership doesn't understand the data is so important to enable
their internal ai agents to be you know to be able to like you know building this memory and contact
engineering capabilities they tend to move very fast they won't see the business outcomes you know
you know of course you can see the immediate some business outcomes but if you want to see this
compounding fact you have to build your strong data foundation and then have all this automation
happen be you know without any you know your engineering or data team um you know um you know
basically be the bottleneck so that's like a one my biggest observation that was happening in the
industry today i would say like you know prioritize long term build your strong data and um you know
analytics foundation that will help you build your internal kind of like a mode that you can
grow and compound over time and to your second question i guess uh what cause maybe can you
yeah i was just curious that like companies were doing all of this workflow except for maybe the
right most autonomous agent like companies were already doing this at least advanced companies
to your point but with gen ai and just kind of redoing this stack with agents
and so forth what are some of the insights examples um that are that you're able to glean
out of this that was not possible before yeah okay great question i think um you know a lot of ai
uh sorry a lot you know a lot of data platform companies like a snowflake and databricks they
have leveraged um you know particular like a large language models like you know anthropic they
basically embed
um cloud code underneath of their platform now like for data team members including myself
i have not been doing coding to be honest for you know a few years and now i can go to any kind of
data platforms like especially like on databricks and you know snowflake i can build data pipelines
on my own without any data engineer so you know you guys heard about the ctos became like ics and
that's really you know happening today
i mean any technical executives can build technical data pipeline data models on our own i
don't need any data analysts to work for me to build some basic essential data pipelines and um
and second thing is you know the ai reasoning piece is really powerful um historically machine
learning everyone called them as a black box model you know very fancy but we don't know why
but now with ai reasoning we can really to end users why we can use AI reasoning to build data
pipelines um which one is
the specification to protect any Apa VM or any fra blender implements because they can have
a wide number or actually you know multiple host state which has a fixed заing scale up to 10 fou
interesting
okay
getting insights from all the product data and every marketing campaign is
bottleneck because we don't have enough data engineers and we don't have enough
analysts. So one of the key things that I think what you're trying to convey in
this is like, Hey, now you can do it as an operator.
You can build this data pipeline.
You can actually derive insights from it and now you are unblocked by doing
this.
Yeah. And what I heard, you know, from, you know,
some large industry conferences like Snowflake and Databricks conferences,
I heard, you know,
because now with all this AI powered tooling, you know,
especially on the data side,
people only need to spend about 10% of time they used to spend, you know,
building data pipelines, you know, data, data modeling, you know,
all this stuff and you can build things so much, you know, very, very fast.
So that's really the game changer for,
for a lot of the people in the field. And, you know, you can really,
if you understand this kind of best practice architecture,
you can build like end product very, very quickly.
And you see the business outcomes. But my advice is,
if you really building this, you know, AI powered GTM,
GTM operating system, make sure you have the data layer don't jump, you know,
even Sakib, I'm pretty sure they have data store somewhere, you know,
make sure like you have that data layer that can compound over time.
You out keep all the information you have. Even today, you start with, you know,
10,000 records and over the course of next six months,
you may grow to a hundred thousand,
make sure all these things you have the record keep somewhere. And then that,
you know, can be res, you know, can be used for your agents.
That's interesting. And I think I'm sure you have some of this in the next slide.
So I'll, I'll hold my question, but I think what would be great if you can,
can walk us through a couple of examples of like,
this is the insight that you are able to derive,
or this is the outcome that you are looking, you did with your team and,
it'll become more grounded and this framework can be codified there.
Yeah, of course. Yeah. I've definitely have examples and demos.
Please stay with me. So yeah. So let's talk about business impact.
You know,
I have been talking to a lot of companies and also advise a couple of
enterprise.
And I've seen, you know, customers,
my customers in the last few months and this is a real business impact once
they implement this framework. So, you know, by, you know,
after server as AI and data advisor to tech companies you know,
and guided them on similar initiatives,
I've seen up to three X left in their pipeline conversion in terms,
you know, real revenue and why, because the whole loop,
the system of AI operating system,
that's all in a machine learning accuracy prediction of who they should engage.
And the AI agents tell you, you know you know,
right now you know, who and how you want to engage. And and this really GTM stack,
X shoot the, your rec,
the AI recommendation and then the pipeline convert converting to revenue before
your buyer really engage with, with your field. Two examples,
Anthropic,
where you know,
what cars he he works at I had the former team members
who were part of the in Anthropics data engineering and
analytics teams. And they, you know,
I had learned so much from my conversations with them and they're really
building very,
very strong data foundations over there by pulling all their product usage
signal and all behaviors is Sarah, but also like their, you know,
go to market activities,
and all the marketing campaigns, you know,
so party signals,
all their data flows into the internal data platforms.
And that really becomes a key part of the Anthropic growth engine.
And then my former company Snowflake that also doing very,
very similar things. You know, I watched so many you know,
there's some, some keynotes and also, you know,
a lot of key announcements about the AI capabilities, you know,
horizon contacts and con contacts,
you know, sense, et cetera.
So I'm not going to cover too much product features, et cetera,
but those two companies, I would say like industry examples, how, you know,
they're leveraging the AI operating system to help, you know,
go to market and gross. Lastly,
but I want to show you a quick demo,
which I built for this particular webinar. I'm going to switch my screen.
Before you get to demo, there's an interesting question,
which is Asher saying that I need to build this data layer,
to AI system. Yeah. Cool.
Great. Yeah, please. You know, we can talk.
No, I was asking like what tools do you recommend for enrichment?
Oh, enrichment. I would say, you know,
there's like a tools if you're talking about like, you know,
account enrichment or contact enrichment, there's like a, you know,
clay and there's like a very popular application and also like a more
traditional application.
So you can use, you know, capital IQ SMP,
and also on Zoom info. There's definitely a lot of enrichment tools,
but I always say pick the one that fits, you know,
best for your company needs. And also, you know, your budget,
always those enrichment tools will cost money.
You don't need to make the perfect data, but pick the best tool for,
for your use case.
No, I think, I think I agree with that because I think there are a lot of
enrichment tools out there.
And I'll give you a personal personal experience, right?
I was advising a company and they were using one popular tool. I wouldn't,
I wouldn't name them on this webinar, but it starts with Z, but
I, I just ran a prompt. I just built like a skill on Claude,
covert,
and I was able to get much better results on the ICP and the persona
than the enrichment tool. So I would say, even if you ask Claude,
and now you can also,
you can also connect your Claude cowork with XR and some of these search
tools,
which would allow you to scrape a lot more information about your ICP and
enrichment overall. So again, there are many things you can do.
And instead of just using the specific enrichment tools,
you can also use existing LLMs and some of the search infrastructure now.
Yeah. Yeah. You know, I, I liked Roger's idea, you know,
now with a lot of AI native, you know, platforms, they,
they are also trying to sell the JS at, you know,
my suggestions don't limit to those, you know, traditional, like, you know,
enrichment platform, like Zooming for SMP, you know, capital IQ, you know,
experiment with some, some new tools, and maybe you,
you could find, you know, cheaper options and maybe, you know,
even more powerful for capabilities. So, you know, yeah. Okay.
So next I'm going to do a demo here,
if you feel with me, hopefully you guys can see it. Okay.
So now you're looking at this screen. I built this quick demo,
which is for this webinar, it's called SignalSphere AI.
So this thing,
imagine this is our live account and contact activation platform,
beautiful, you know, a very big enterprise company.
On, you know, on this UI, you see there's like a co-pilot and also, you know,
autonomous,
AI agent. Step one, let's look on the left side,
basically the input. We have a lot of signals coming from, you know,
tens or hundreds of different systems, like, you know, like GitHub,
there's some engagement, you know, in a traditional GTM model,
this tends to be a noise. No one will look at the,
what's happening in GitHub. No one in marketing understand that, you know,
very, very few people in marketing and technical. But now with, you know,
all this,
automated data pipeline, we're able to collect our data and our basic machine learning,
you know, model can really do, you know,
predictive analytics on top of this, you know, either structured, unstructured,
or even semi-structured video data, everything, every signal you can get.
And then for here.
Can you zoom in a little bit? I think folks are having a hard time.
I'm just making sense of it. Just do like a, yeah.
Can you see it now? I'm not sure. Like my screen is a little bit odd.
Can you see?
No, it's still too blurry and too much,
but you can just maybe speak to specific pieces of it that you're maybe use your
cursor to.
Yeah. Okay. Here, here. Now you can see the feed.
The basically the data comes from different data sources, you know,
tens of a hundred different data sources that that's,
that's what happened. That's Snowflake. We have, you know,
more than 200 data sources flowing into our basically, you know,
Snowflake internal platforms.
And you basically have a lot of accounts happening, you know,
Snowflake will target more than 300,000 accounts, a lot of, you know,
noise over there, you know, and particularly for this, you know,
demo, we have three big, three examples here.
One is for sale and then second one is Airtable.
And the third one is Figma. And then, you know,
for this particular, okay, sorry.
For this Figma particular account, we actually,
you know, based on the other signals we have, you know,
Figma is a company with 1500 employees and you know,
we have, you know,
many many signals happen underneath of this particular AI
platform. And, you know, we, our machine learning did the scoring,
give us a score of 76 out of 100.
So what does that entail? That's really the AI agent,
reasoning piece comes,
comes in, you know, you, you basically, you're thinking about,
you can click, sorry, this is a bit small right now.
I even cannot see this. You can basically start something called, you know,
a swarm switch, basically to activate your AI agents.
Right now we have three AI agents. One is the SDR research agents.
SDR used to spend, based on my knowledge and working relationship,
they spent, you know,
hours you know,
just doing manual research of going to this application,
going to that application, going to this dashboard and, you know,
just stitch all the data and information together and come up with their own,
own kind of proposal or, you know, or theory.
But now with this AI, you know, research, sorry,
with this SDR research agent with one click,
you got everything done for you. And as you know,
you don't actually need any SDR to help you do any research here.
And then the second agent is copyright agent. Basically, I can write, you know,
an email copy for you based on the context, you know,
you have in your data platform and generate this email draft for you.
The last thing is your GTM router. Basically, it can connect,
you know, even this email draft, your outreach to your, you know, Salesforce,
or even maybe schedule a meeting between, you know,
your AE and also your, your potential customer,
or, you know, or, you know, or maybe a VP of product,
et cetera. And that really becomes the reasoning part of pillar of,
of your, your AI agent. And then the,
the next one is the, you know, the action, you know, you,
here you can go back to the co-pilot and then you can,
you can approve this specific action here.
And that basically will activate all the next steps for you.
Once you approve the message or email template,
you want to send to your customers. This part is, you know,
we're seeing like the humans still stay in the loop before any message goes out.
This is quite important concept.
As we're thinking about your strategic accounts,
your strategic persona or your VIP customers,
you don't actually,
don't have to be a VIP customer.
You don't actually have to be a VIP customer.
You don't want to have the auto, you know,
automatic agents to do something on your behalf.
You always want your AEs,
your SDRs to do something before anything goes out, you know,
maybe for low tier, I think, you know, accounts like middle,
middle market, or even especially like SMB customers,
you don't have enough SDRs or AEs to cover all those accounts.
You could potentially leverage your, you know, those AI agents capability,
to send the emails on your behalf.
And maybe the call to action is they can talk to someone live if they really need to.
So that's, that's the way I think how this entire, you know,
AI powered and machine learning powered, you know, GTM operating system can really help you,
you know, not just activate your pipeline,
but how you can orchestrate your entire customer journey, but still human in the loop.
And this just concludes my,
my quick demo about, you know,
how the UI will look like,
you know, for this account and contact activation platform.
I want to pause a second here.
I know this screen is a little bit busy and I try my best to,
how to fit this screen to the,
to the,
to this particular demo and happy to,
you know,
share this thing,
this particular demo,
and I'm happy to, you know, share this thing,
this demo with anyone who wants to learn a little bit details on,
you know,
how,
how it works.
But no,
this live demo is a little bit hard.
And,
and I also understand the audience today is,
you know,
tend to be non-technical.
I'm trying to,
you know,
kind of close the gap with a little bit demo and previous,
all my previous content,
you know,
a little bit more like a high level.
Cool.
Great.
Super helpful to kind of bring it also home with the,
with the demo.
The one,
some of the things that are sort of still relevant,
right?
You basically have different data sources that sometimes tell different
conflicting stories around and,
and,
and different point to different types of trends.
You have to,
you have all these conflicting data are many times conflicting data points.
I guess in case of humans,
we were able to sort of do some,
be able to navigate,
the grayness of this,
how an inferred things,
how does that happen in the agent tech workflow where you have conflicting data sources that an agent is then using in kind of driving this actions and driving results on it?
Yeah,
I would say like the data engineering piece,
you know,
or maybe we caught it in the machine learning where there is a feature engineering piece of quite important to make sure you orchestrate all the data flowing.
Let's say you're back to snowflake,
we had more than 200 data sources flowing properly,
building the data pipelines and structured data in,
in your data platform.
You know,
that's like a really key and make sure,
you know,
that we invest like a basically on the foundation,
the infrastructure to build for longterm.
Um,
every single thing you build,
you make sure you have this,
this in mind,
you know,
don't rush to just,
Oh,
I want to skip this particular step and just jump to the end product.
Uh,
you know,
that's really like,
from like a builder,
um,
you know,
perspective,
I always want to build longterm things and I want to make sure like everyone understand that piece,
you know,
every dollar,
every,
you know,
hour you invest building something in,
in your data platform.
Um,
that's,
that's quite,
quite important.
Don't skip that step.
Cool.
And one more,
some of the names you mentioned at the tools are quite expensive,
like the,
the notoriously,
the,
the marketing operations,
growth stack tends to be super expensive.
SAS tools.
What,
uh,
and not everyone can afford them.
Uh,
also,
I feel like,
I don't,
I don't know.
I would love that.
You know,
I'm curious about your,
your,
your point of view about in this age of Jenny,
I,
how much of that is relevant to buy these,
these tools individually.
So what would you recommend to someone working in a startup starting early on?
Like what is a,
what is a minimum viable,
uh,
step growth stack to start with?
Yeah.
Um,
I would say,
you know,
trying to buy those tools with,
multiple capabilities,
not just,
you know,
CRM,
not just email to all,
like,
you know,
you can definitely buy some of the most expensive,
high capability tools like a salesforce on my cattle,
and they definitely will cost a lot of money and trying to evaluate,
maybe some tools,
whether they can have both,
you know,
combination of blinding curators.
So,
you know,
CRM email,
um,
maybe like,
you know,
even like outreach and maybe,
um,
campaign management,
you know,
all this,
I don't know.
I cannot recommend any tool with all these capabilities,
maybe rather than what costs or suck.
Keep,
they know some tools,
but my,
my,
my suggestion is trying to evaluate the tools with multiple capabilities.
And then,
you know,
then you spend less dollars or invest less on some of those
tooling capabilities and,
uh,
and,
you know,
invest more,
even have one people in your data organization,
or maybe part of the growth organization,
just build all these data pipeline data foundation capabilities for you.
And from there,
you,
you know,
you can work with partner marketing,
dimension or counter marketing,
or even,
you know,
uh,
community.
And,
you know,
develop relations,
all those teams,
you know,
to build like the AI agents,
um,
you know,
uh,
workflows at scale.
So that's,
that's my recommendation,
you know,
investing in your data,
even one people that will unlock a lot of potentials for you.
Yeah.
You spoke like a,
spoke like a true,
uh,
data person.
Like,
Hey,
if you don't have good data,
nothing,
no,
no agents are going to work for you.
Right.
Uh,
it makes sense.
And I think on the,
on the question about tools,
right?
I think what I always feel about it is like people have it inwards.
Uh,
they think about a tool force and see where it applies.
I rather think about like building something very quickly and then extending it with tools when I want to scale.
Right.
And I think that's the part that I always,
uh,
allows me to use less tools versus like getting excited about a tool and then trying to fit into my existing work overall.
Yeah.
We have a few more questions.
Uh,
I think on the,
there's one question around on the raw signals,
right?
Uh,
which data sources are you actually pulling from?
And are you using,
uh,
any platform like to ingest or you do build ingestion yourself?
Yeah.
So that's like a game changer over the last,
I would say,
you know,
few months now,
like if you go to the list,
you know,
AI powered data platforms like a snowflake,
right?
You actually can build like basically data ingestion pipelines,
even natively in snowflake.
And that's like a game changer,
you know,
back to even two years ago,
my team at snowflake,
we had like a data engineers just to build data pipelines,
you know,
using,
basically like a sub party data ingestion tools and that costs money.
And then,
you know,
we would have some people monitoring the data pipeline,
pipeline set up,
setting up the alerts,
all this stuff costs money,
but now with all this AI powered data pipeline capabilities,
you can basically like build something very cheap,
like low cost,
very low cost.
You know,
even someday,
you know,
I go to,
if in the future I go to work for a company,
just,
you know,
like,
like a CTO become like I see CTO,
I could do almost anything,
like a team of 10 people,
like just by myself,
to be honest,
I know what to build.
I know how the best look like.
And I have all this AI powered capabilities,
the tooling,
the data platforms.
I mean,
I even don't know,
I don't need to write too much code and I can just prompt with what I want.
I want the AI,
you know,
agents,
to help me build something,
you know,
very quickly.
Right.
So I think this is really the game changer.
You know,
yeah,
right now,
anyone with a technical background can build amazing stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
It's really powerful.
I think even Roger and probably can build something,
you know,
will cause some people,
they are building some stuff,
you know?
Yeah.
So that's a game changer for,
for,
for me,
particularly on the data pipeline inside.
I,
I have some,
some good Ryan,
Ryan,
thank you for being so active in the chat and responding.
And so he feels like the session,
someone would charge for it.
I mean,
I,
I'll see if I find something,
I'll pay for it.
If someone is charging for it and to see it again.
But thanks.
Thanks Ryan for the vote of confidence that this would be a paid session somewhere.
But I think our goal is to always keep it free.
Our goal is to share the knowledge,
have everyone upskill to become more AI native.
But I,
I,
I love,
I love the positivity here.
Yeah.
And by the way,
on that note,
if there are any of you here attending,
we'll be happy to,
we'll be happy to talk to you again.
And so we have a lot of people in our community here today.
We have a lot of people who are here to support us in any way,
you can sign up for any of these to support us in any way.
It's gonna be a lot of work.
And so for those of you here attending would love to come in and give an
interesting use case that you want to highlight.
Please reach out to us.
I'll,
I'll draw this drop in my email here.
Please,
please reach out and with the use case that you want to demo,
and we would love to.
Love to talk to you.
more questions i will try to answer those questions asing but if i if i have to boil down
two two key takeaways right and uh i'll put on my put on my hat uh uh one is if you want to do it
do it now and i think that could be the slogan for entropic uh just do it now uh and okay uh you
don't need to pay me for that uh some of the audience member came up with that you can you
can deal with them directly but i think the second one is i think a couple of people texted me also
is like hey biryanis do not have potatoes i think we if you all agree on that those are two big
takeaways for the session if you don't take anything else uh but any any any last last
comments from the speakers sakep kwan uh yeah my last takeaway i was trying to um
write some post something in the chat you know it's a great time for everyone you know technical
non-technical to be with ai especially like you know clouds and all these powerful you know models
uh and then from my angle is don't forget to invest in data and in your foundation you know don't
rush just jump into ai directly that will you know i heard from so many people like my ai is lying to
me because it didn't have the context for for your particular organization and your company so don't
miss that piece um uh first of all anyone who doesn't like alu and uh biryani is having a lot of
problems with their own business and they're having really terrible biryani um they should
come over to my house and i'll make them good biryani um it has to be fried potatoes it can't
be just boiled potatoes so there's a texture element to all of this um i want to tell you
guys this short story which is basically like my older son when he was in third grade he's an
overachiever um he's on the spectrum and wanted to learn more about fourth grade math and english and
he's like i'm gonna teach myself an app and claude to teach him fourth grade math and english wow
um and i i can deploy that app and stuff and everything and uh share that i think it's very
important to understand that there will be a time when people at every level can deploy their own
apps and every level of understanding can deploy their own apps and that is going to change how
software is deployed and seen and done in every way and right now my third grader is building his
own app and he's building his own video game that he continuously keeps on adding to um or my second
grader who's going into third grade uh it's just going to be a very different world um and we need
to kind of look at it from that perspective rather than saying hey do we keep on adjusting to the old
ways of doing business so i'll leave it at that that's amazing no this is so good thank you so
much first of all thanks akib and kuan uh for taking time and sharing what you learn and what
you build and again thank you so much for the audience
uh for asking these questions again our goal is to keep this informal and this is more of an
interaction and us helping uh everyone answer their questions about using ai and their day-to-day
workflow uh so thank you so much for joining wakas i'll let you close the close the loop if you want
to or we can end the session here this is great we will follow up with some of the insights as well
as the recording uh and uh the uh the speakers for the next session yes thank you all thank you all
wow
you